bill Barnett is American a polls he
moved to the city in 1973 so hurricanes
unfortunately are not new to him he was
also the city's mayor during hurricanes
Charlie and Wilma he joins us now on the
phone mayor Barnett good morning to you
good morning so unfortunately you've
heard this song before I'm curious about
what's your assessment of what you're
learning about herma this morning in the
light of day your city was hit pretty
hard we see yeah we we we we took a real
hard hit I I'm comparing it to Wilma and
Wilma was paled in comparison to her
myself I'm out now I have been out with
with some of the crew just during the
early evaluations and that there are I
mean luckily and thankfully so far not a
lot of structural damage I will tell you
that there are roads blocked there
they're flooding there are some
neighborhoods that are that are badly
flooded the I'm looking at a tree right
now that is on top of a transformer box
so as Florida power light is going to
have a massive massive massive job not
just in Naples but all they didn't you
know but we the good news and you said a
little earlier about the storm surge a
storm surge here was predicted to be
anywhere between 12 and 18 feet and we
really dodged that we had minimal
minimal storm surge still have a lot of
water though and there are a couple of
neighborhoods we can't even get any but
that's a bit of good news surge was only
seven feet but the winds reaching a
hundred and forty two miles per hour in
Naples what has been the damage to the
infrastructure well you know that that
that was a gust that was recorded out of
the at the Naples Airport and III don't
think that was sustained but that was
the highest reported us ever I think
that was the highest in the state of
Florida yesterday I don't know but
that's a record that nobody wants to
have anyway but uh
the only structural damage down there
was it blew the roof off I we have a
fire station there but it's only been
for you know the airport so nobody heard
and that's that was that best or worse
we can live with it for sure and and you
know other than that as I said while
crews are out I see the heavy duty the
heavy equipment the the loaders and
everything else we're doing every single
Street individually and the fire guys
are out first responders are out all the
city utilities people are out so it's
going to be a massive cleanup instead of
the expense if I know that but you know
so far I haven't heard of any injuries
or or or no loss of life spend on and so
I'm really really pleased about that our
preparations we're good maril thank you
so much thank you so much you're more
than welcome and thank you we wish
everyone in there in the Naples area the
very best thank you